التصعيد الحاصل بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
والملف النووي الايراني شكلات طبق الساخنه
على مائده الحوار بين رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه وصانعي القرار في اسرائيل
غامبول
سياستنا مشتركه ونحن نحاول العمل معا لدرء
الخطا
هي عمل اسرائيل كل ما بيسعها لمن ايران من
امتلاك سلاح النووي ونحن مصممون على تنفيذ
هذه السياسه في الوقت الذي نجح نتنياه فيه
لسنوات في تهميش الموضوع الفلسطيني اعاده
التصعيده في ظل حكومه تشمل وزراء متطرفين
الى الواجهه وتاتي زياره لينكن لرام الله
كما مسؤولين امريكيين اخرين رساله
لاسرائيل بان توسيع دائره التطبيع بين
اسرائيل ودول المنطقه وحتى مواجهه ايران
باتت مرتبطه بعدم تدمير حل دولتين نحن
نؤمن ونسعى لتنفيذ رؤيه حل الدولتين وكما
قلت لرئيس الوزراء فان اي شيء يبعدنا عن
هذه الرؤيه هو بمفهومنا يمس بامن اسرائيل
على المدى البعيد
وبهويتنا كدوله يهوديه ديموقراطيه
اللافته ان زياره بلنك الى جانب مدير
السياعي الموجود في اسرائيل تزامنت مع شني
ثلاث غارات متفرقه على اهداف داخل ايران
وفي الاقليم طالت القدرات البالستيه وسلاح
المسيرات بعيدا عن الكلام الدبلوماسي
الامريكي والاسرائيلي فان ارث التوتر في
العلاقه بين نتنياهو اداره بايدين يلقي
بظلاله على الحوار الامريكي الاسرائيلي مع
الحكومه الجديده ايضا واشنطن نقلت قلقها
مرتين مرتين من الملف الفلسطيني والانفجار
الحاصل ومره ثانيه من الملف الايراني
والخشيه من مفاجات الاسرائيليه زياد حلبي
العربيه